[Music]
hello and welcome to dear John and Hank
or as I like to call dear Hank and John
this is a podcast where I John Green
along with my brother Hank green offers
some dubious advice answer your
questions and give you all the week's
news for Mars and AFC Wimbledon Hank how
are you I'm doing good
John you and I just had a conference
call wasn't that enjoyable I love a good
conference call I always thought that
the whole point of being a working
novelist was that you didn't have to
have meetings but it turns out that I
still do have to have meetings in fact I
have to have an astonishing number of
them all so Hank to be completely
upfront with you I have a hangover long
I threw up from drinking oh wow for the
first time since my 30th birthday yeah
what are what are you a teen well I
dunno I hadn't had a drink in about 45
days and then I had a few of them and
it's III think my tolerance had been
significantly affected and it was a
difficult uh it was a difficult and
painful evening and indeed it has been a
difficult and painful day I don't want
to I don't want to undersell it there is
absolutely nothing to recommend how I
feel right now but we'll talk more about
alcohol during the during the advice
portion of the podcast but everything
else is good with you yeah last night I
had a glass of wine and a chocolate cake
not a whole chocolate cake just a piece
of chocolate cake it was wonderful well
you aren't you a study in moderation
would you like a poem give me a poem
John alright I see you've been
complaining a lot about the poems lately
especially that they sound it's not go
away
it's just I'm just commenting so I'm
gonna try to out what I'm gonna try to
do today is I'm gonna read a very famous
very short William Carlos Williams poem
let me try to read it in a way that
isn't so poem II and then next week I'm
gonna read an even less poem a poem but
Hank please please take careful note of
this poem I want you to listen to it
closely not just for this week but also
for next week okay okay this poem is
called this is just to say by William
Carlos Williams
I have eaten the plums that were in the
icebox and which you were probably
saving
for breakfast forgive me they were
delicious so sweet and so cold at the
bottom this is just to say by William
Carlos Williams I didn't do that to poem
he did I yeah I like it
I'm down it still sounds like a poem I
don't know there's something about it
like when you're just reading a book
it's it sounds like you're reading a
book and when you're reading a poem it
sounds like you're reading a poem I'm
not sure what the what the thing I mean
I I can read that one much more poem II
I have eaten the plums that were in the
icebox
you were probably saving for breakfast
anyway I love that poem despite the fact
that I don't really know for sure what
an icebox is is that just a refrigerator
I suppose that's where I would put my
plums but I think we've all been in that
situation both literally and
metaphorically in our lives with those
we love where we must seek their
forgiveness
because despite the fact that they were
saving something and and we should have
we should have honored that we are
overcome by our own need by our own
personal hunger and that's human but
it's also very sad my wife has this
awful habit it's not an awful habit my
wife wife has this habit that isn't is
bad for her because of my habit and that
habit is that she saves the French fries
that she wants the most for last now
this seems like a terrible like idea to
me because you want to eat the best
french fries while they're still hot and
before someone else has a chance to eat
them but she says and she does this was
all food too not just french fries she
says the one she wants the most for last
and so I finished my food and then
whatever is left over there is
Katherine's food and I and I grab but
then I've taken if I take one of her
things then it's like it's definitely
going to be one of the things that she's
most excited about and I'm like get that
into your mouth as soon as possible cuz
otherwise you don't know what's gonna
happen to it that asteroid could hit you
know the whole the place could burn down
there could be a fire situation you got
to get those good things into your mouth
soon you know Hank people often say
that the advice here on dear Hank and
John isn't particularly good but let me
submit that the advice that you just
gave get that in your mouth as soon as
possible is brilliant advice get that in
your mouth as soon as possible that's
that's that's what that's that's what we
believe here in our family was it get
that in your out as soon as possible or
put that in your mouth as soon as
possible either way great in a good cell
yeah but do you want to give some more
advice or or possibly just just
pontificate at after someone asks us a
question yeah absolutely this is gonna
be one very humorous humor podcast today
you wanna you want to ask the first
question yeah sure I'll ask question
from Rhett who asks dear Hank and John
what is your definition of the word art
oh gosh well I kind of make a point not
to define the word art too much but I I
like to think that art is something that
someone or someone's has or have put
into the world to make my life more
interesting I like it like I think that
art I think that art has to has to be
created for an audience and I think it
has to be created as a gift for that
audience and other than that I don't try
to judge it too much yeah I I have no
answer for this question at all
that's it seems like way too difficult a
thing to try to try and put a box around
yeah
so I I say my definition of the word
artist the very practice of not trying
to define the word art Rhett yeah well
you know my wife who is a museum curator
and the host of the art assignment would
completely agree with you that that the
question of what art is is one of the
least interesting questions that you can
ask around art yeah I kind of feel that
way as a religious person about the the
question of like does God exist which I
find to be a completely uninteresting
question and yet like people act like
it's the only interesting question about
religion but not to me anyway
can we move on to another question Hank
we can I think this question is from
Gerard and and it
it involves the theme of today's podcast
Dear John and Hank I am a distiller and
I was wondering what your thoughts were
on the US legal drinking age from a
scientific perspective alcohols effect
on the developing mind etc and the
sociological one effects on young
people's perceptions of alcohol also I
have to ask what do you enjoy drinking
well well Gerrard I can tell you what I
regret drinking from last night rose a
wine that's half red and half white I
don't don't think I'll be drinking rose'
again for a little while yeah I mean I I
am concerned III think there are big and
legitimate concerns about the effect
that alcohol consumption can have on
developing brains there are also big and
legitimate concerns about the effect
that alcohol consumption can have on
grown-up brains and grownup livers and
yeah I am NOT a I am NOT a big advocate
for alcohol which i think is a fairly
dangerous drug that is treated pretty
casually in American culture but but I
do enjoy drinking in in moderation but
gosh I do not enjoy drinking and
immoderation which is what I did last
night yeah I it's it's a it's a tricky
question because you can look at some
countries where the legal drinking age
is lower and say that you know binge
drinking is less of a problem in those
places but I don't know that that would
necessarily be the case immediately if
we lowered the drinking age in America
because of course then you know the the
culture around alcohol and it's sort of
you know its place in taboo and teenage
rebellion would not change at least for
a while and then you have then you have
people who are really excited to buy and
be able to acquire alcohol easily at the
same time it doesn't seem that making it
illegal for young people prevents them
from consuming lots of it maybe but I
would say that it it almost certainly
decreases the number of people who
consume lots of it I don't know I feel
like maybe we aren't experts in this
field Hank what do you enjoy drinking
that was
Gerard's main question well I do I am an
expert in the field of the the things
that I personally enjoy drinking I don't
get to drink a ton anymore because I
take a medicine that that is not
suggested to be taken with with alcohol
and I take it every day but I enjoy beer
I'm a fan of beer of many different
types of beer I like but basically at
this point having you know not been able
to enjoy beer much I just want any beer
any beer at all but that I also really
enjoy gin drinks and he oh I really like
gin and and I like some you know various
Brown liquors such as such as oh no I
gotta ask you to stop your no you have
to stop you're not you're not eating me
I can't I can't go on you know Brown
liquors I that was it for me I'm sorry
but we have to move on that's I'm
physically ill this question the next
one is from Sophia who says dear Hank
and John I'm Sophia I'm 12 and I'm
having a midlife crisis who should I
play off for on Mario Kart oh I'll tell
you Hank as someone who had a lot of
midlife crises when he was 12 I
sympathize Sophia oh it was terrible it
was so challenging being 12 not just
because the Mario Cart issue you haven't
made your Mario Kart commitment but
there's so many other commitments that
you haven't made in life so many paths
that you might take and in a way that's
liberating but in another way it's so
constraining because it just the choices
feel infinite and it's only once you
start to narrow your choices and in in
some ways like that's sad when you
narrow your choices in life but in other
ways it's it's so freeing because you
don't have to feel this the infinite
array of possibilities that you might
now I assume Sophia that you're playing
a Super Mario Kart for the Super
Nintendo right as I was when I was 12
and so your choices are Donkey Kong
Princess Peach Luigi Mario
toad and Yoshi was wasn't that it Hank
was there anything else that sounds
about right probably missing a couple
there was none of this like Wario
business you know I've but I think
Bowser was in there that was her of
course but you know you don't want to
play with Bowser because if you're
looking for top speed then you need to
look to donkey kong not Bowser and if
you're looking for literally anything
else oh and and toad of course but but
you don't want toad either total Santos
your real core choices here Sophia are
Princess Peach and again I'm assuming
that you're playing this game 20 years
ago 25 years ago
you're real your choices are the
Princess Peach and Luigi Mario is just a
poor man's Luigi and toad is just a poor
man's Princess Peach and you can make an
argument for Donkey Kong if you're on a
track that really really benefits high
top speed over acceleration but almost
all of the mario kart tracks require
good acceleration at least coming out of
a jump turn so I'm gonna say I'm gonna
say Luigi I'm gonna say that that on a
day to day basis if you need a character
who's kind of gonna be at the center of
your Mario Kart playing life for the
next you know 10 to 15 years
you're gonna want Luigi there are other
people who are better in in moments but
you want consistency at this point in
your life Sophia you want someone you
can count on and that someone is Luigi
well as someone who is slightly younger
than John Green and thus played mostly
Mario Kart on the Nintendo 64 I have to
say that Donkey Kong is the way to go
especially if you're like me the kind of
Mario Kart player who just isn't very
good and and is going to be flying all
over the place and needs a guy who can
who can really stick when he when he's
crashes into other players and into
objects on the crash I'm sorry what is
the possible what is the possible
benefit of Donkey Kong in any version of
Mario
okay he's he's heavy he he's heavy so he
doesn't get pushed around it so much so
when you left me and you can't control
characters with your fine motor skills
which I can't cuz I'm one
I don't play enough video games and too
my hands don't work very well you got
you it's good to have it's good to have
a donkey kong so that you can you can
plow through any situation and you don't
slow down as much when you go over the
grass donkey kong's got it going on also
he's a big big monkey which is great you
know I don't I don't dislike your
argument I think that for an entry-level
mariokart player Donkey Kong is an
excellent choice high top speed strength
weight as you said doesn't get hurt as
much going through the grass although
because the acceleration is so slow
coming out of the grass you don't get
back to top speed it takes forever to
get back to top speed and if you're on a
beach course in my opinion Donkey Kong
is just not not the best ah my argument
for Luigi and I I know that you can tell
I feel strongly about this but like my
argument for Luigi and I don't I don't
want to you know be mean to you about
your your point but I just feel like
Luigi is an everyday every course choice
for Mario Kart and I feel like Donkey
Kong you know is sometimes a good choice
but sometimes a disastrous one so if we
want Sophia to be finishing like solid
seconds and thirds when she plays with
her friends I think Luigi's the better
choice I agree I agree there's also of
course something to be said for choosing
a character that you feel personally
connected to because really is it all
about winning or is it about feeling
good about no it's about winning game
playing we're not talking about life
we're talking about Mario Kart the most
important thing that humans have ever
done together well I uh I appreciate to
Sofia's question and I appreciate John
you you have AG a lot of a lot of deep
and and significant thoughts about this
okay here's another question this one's
from Geoff he writes Dear John and Hank
what can an average person with few
financial resources do to slow climate
change people always say that I should
get an electric
or solar panels but those types of
things cost a lot of money correct a
great question Hank and but please tell
tell us tell us what to do well the
thing in your life that consumes the
most energy is in fact not your car it
is your house so the thing you can do is
set your thermostat at a more reasonable
place and especially in the winter which
is when we consume most of our resources
unless you live in a very nice a nice
tropical place put on a sweater and do
the Jimmy Carter and and and you know
have your house be in the high 60s
instead of a little 70s stuff like that
here's where you save most of your like
your of your energy the the heating and
cooling of your of your home though we
do not ever talk about it is the
number-one thing that that the number
one source of carbon emissions in our
lives unless you like I do
spend a tremendous amount of time on
airplanes I also spend a lot of time on
airplanes and I feel horribly guilty
about it and I'm trying to fly less but
instead I keep flying more I just got my
like diamond platinum medallion from the
airline that I fly regularly Delta and I
just it feels like failure it feels like
every time I get one of those new
medallions are invalid it just I just
feel that I've done something terribly
wrong because I know the carbon
emissions are epic and also it just
means that I'm spending lots of time
away from my family but I can't stop
Hank I can't stop getting in airplanes
yeah it's hard it's hard to be John
Green and it is hard to it's hard to say
no when people want you to do cool
things I understand that no it's not
hard to be me well it's hard to it's
hard to be everyone John but but I am
fascinated by the idea that of course
what we think about when we think about
solving or having a smaller impact on
the earth is like what we can can
acquire to help us do that but really of
course any acquisition is is more
resources being being spent and like
there are certainly arguments to say
that solar panels or an electric car
would be a you know resources spent well
and possibly resources that overall will
have you know lessen intense impact on
the environment then they're not
purchasing those things but really a lot
of what we can do is just to do less
consumption at all and that's uh that's
a difficult thing because it's not
exciting and nobody's gonna have a
really fun marketing campaign for it and
you can't you can't you know drive it
around and look cool in it but that's
that's really but but it is in fact
something that that all people
regardless of level of income can do and
that's just consume less and and in
general consume less electricity which
means biking places or not less
electricity you consume less fuel of all
kinds which means biking places and and
living in smaller homes and doing things
that we don't necessarily want to do but
they're free so you're saying that
really there there is no acquisition
that's carbon neutral well yes there
would be I mean solar panels would
absolutely be an acquisition that that
would be you know net negative on the
amount of carbon released into the
environment hmm okay so I should get
solar panels yes if you can if you can
afford them absolutely please we need
first adopters to drive down the price
of solar panels at as it continues to
and and hopefully will continue to do
for a long time until it is available
for everyone which will be really really
great because not only then will we have
less impact on the environment but we
will have a distributed power system
which is much less likely to completely
in catastrophic ly fail in the event of
a large-scale solar flare that could in
the current state of the American
electricity infrastructure create
basically a complete vino destruction of
our society really yes I'm terrified of
giant solar flares it it is a little bit
is like that would a giant solar flare
like cut the like make the electrical
grid fail for like more than
it would make it could potentially make
it fail for more than a year not real
wait really
yes it's terrifying it is a thing that
we don't worry about it all this is a
terrible comedy podcast but but it is
but as it is like the the number one
thing that we should actually be
worrying about in terms of natural
disasters but since it hasn't ever
happened we don't worry about it at all
but it's the kind of thing that that if
it did happen and and we had you know
the son sent out a solar flare that
would have done this to us just a few
years ago it just happened to be pointed
not at us
it's uh it's it's it's it could be a bad
thing it would take a tremendous amount
of work to get our grid back online in
America okay just one quick follow-up
question Hank I'm sorry to get
distracted here but I didn't know about
this solar flare thing and you know I
like to have a good worry over things
that could kill me and or destroy my
life and I'm kind of astonished that
there's a big one out there that I
wasn't even aware of
now I'm sorry in this scenario where I
have no electric power for a year by the
way I would definitely die but how how
would I charge my phone it might be a
good idea to invest in a bicycle-powered
generator John I am gonna do that I am
gonna invest in solar panels and a
bicycle powered generator and I'm gonna
be the only guy on my block with
electric power and I'll tell you what
nobody's gonna notice and come get you
oh god now I'm truly truly terrified
let's go ahead and just move on to
another question since I've been taken
to an extremely dark place this question
comes from Emily and she writes dear
John and Hank what do you do when the
person you thought was the one leaves
you how do you move past them how do you
start imagining yourself with someone
else how do you get them out of your
head
any thoughts are appreciated including
dubious advice good news Emily dubious
advice is all we have the other good
news is that is that John John is an
expert in this and and I will just have
to step back from the microphone and
have absolutely no no advice for you I'm
sorry ya eggs never been dumped really
right that's not true I've been I've
been dumped but not by but not by girls
who I thought were the one now have you
ever been
have you ever wept from being dumped yes
you don't remember it was a long time
ago John I'm old let me ask you this
have you ever been on your knees and
raised your arms up and said why hast
thou forsaken me with tears streaming
down your cheeks and snot going into
your mouth from your nose as you heave
sobs over having been dumped not over
having been dumped well then you haven't
been dumped okay so here's the thing
Emily it hurts
I've said this a lot over the years it's
something my chaplaincy supervisor said
to me when I got dumped when I was
working as a hospital chaplain but I
found it very helpful it hurts because
it mattered it hurts because it was
important the the grief is intense
because it is real and and because it is
and because the relationship that you
were in was an it was an important one
to you and it needs to be grieved and if
you don't grieve it then you know you're
never going to get through that
experience of loss I know that it sucks
and obviously if it you know obviously
if you're having what you feel to be
like mental or physical health problems
that are related to your grief or if you
feel like your grief is has become
complicated or unhealthy then you should
talk to someone other than your favorite
podcasters about that but but there's
nothing wrong with being sad and I think
the answer to how you get through it is
is time I think everything gets easier
with time and you will eventually
imagine yourself with someone else in
fact you will be with someone else maybe
many more people and and you will
eventually realize I I think or at least
this is what at the conclusion that I've
to that that there is no one as such
there is no like a single flickering
soul out there waiting for you to like
sift through all the other souls and
find the one instead relationships
whether they're romantic relationships
or friendships are things that people
build together over time and and and and
that you know hopefully like I am always
in the process of becoming a good spouse
to my spouse and becoming a good partner
and a good friend to the people I'm
partners and friends with so I think
that you have to look at it as a process
not an event and that you know there
isn't some like needle in a haystack
that you're searching for you know
you're living your life and right now
grief is part of that but it won't
always be such a big part of it good
work John did you like leave Hank and go
like have a diet dr. pepper or something
uh you first of all second of all no I
was reading about Mars if you ever ever
say anything bad about diet dr. pepper
ever again our friendship is over
today's podcast is brought to you by
delicious diet dr. pepper diet dr.
pepper tastes more like regular dr.
pepper which tastes just like heaven
this podcast is brought to you by donkey
kong donkey kong the choice of mario
kart drivers everywhere who actually
care about being stylin and awesome
today's video is brought to you by
crushing solar flares solar flares
waking you up out of your hangover since
2015 to remind you that everything in
life including electricity itself is
precious and fleeting this podcast is
brought to you by Brown liquors brown
liquor is including bourbon and whiskey
drinks that include ethanol water and
things that make them the color Brown
which is making my brother want to vomit
in his own mouth ah ha ha
Brown I don't even mind brown liquors
except when you call them that it's so
upsetting
alright let's move on to another
question Oh Brown liquors
this question is from Jenna dear Hank
and John I'm a freshman in college it
just joined a nerdfighters Club and I
was wondering what a good food to snack
on while you study is what what what
that wasn't my fault
how do you stay focused while you study
Thanks
love you guys I used to love chocolate
chips I just like was like one chocolate
chip every and I try to do it like every
minute or so so just like spread them
out real thin but it's sort of enough to
keep it keep me going and give me
something to look forward to is that
weird it's incredibly weird I also think
that there is no nutritional science to
back up the idea that that's a good
study food but I don't know maybe it
like keeps you working while you try to
understand organic chemistry like every
time you understand a new kind of
bonding or whatever you get a chocolate
chip was that the idea uh no that would
be very few chocolate chips per hour it
was just sort of like you know I have
this thing in my mouth you know
chocolate like dark chocolate chips they
have keep you awake they got that they
got that the old bromide in them and
they're also sort of a little bit bitter
so they're like like a sharp taste to
like make your brain brain continue
braining you got that going on I don't
know it's what I used to do I'd buy like
a big bag of semi-sweet chocolate chips
they're cheap all I can think about is
get it in your mouth as soon as possible
but never like the trick was to only eat
them one at a time when they're really
small and so if you put like five in
your mouth or like a like a handful then
you've just like then you're eating
you're not studying and so just like one
little chocolate chip at a time one
little suck chip it's very slow I'm sure
that works I used to eat a lot of
cinnamon toast crunch as a snack food
but looking back here's what I wish I
had done I wish that I had gone to the
cafeteria and taken some nice fresh
fruit and put it in my little mini
fridge and then I and then cut up little
bowls of fresh fruit to study with
because I think that's the right you
know you get you get a little bit of
sugar and you get a little bit of a kick
from it but but you get it in a fairly
healthy whole food kind
away and so that would be my
recommendation but I will say as a side
note that cinnamon toast crunch is
delicious but done John what about what
about hot pockets though oh my god I did
enjoy a hot pocket or two during college
I you know it's a wonder that I had so
many digestive problems when I was a
college student Hank what with my diet
of cinnamon toast crunch two meals a day
and hot [ __ ] it's two meals a day
because I believed at the time in the
formula day plan I would go at times
weeks without consuming any food that
was not either
one kind of hot pocket or another or
cinnamon toast crunch so I don't think
that I'm the right person to answer this
question uh okay
I yes I also would suggest um ramen
noodles and pop-tarts because let's be
honest it's College all right Hank we've
got a question here from Elliot who
writes Dear John and Hank my question is
aimed at John those are my favorite kind
of questions Elliot as an AFC Wimbledon
supporter I was thrilled when I found
out that you're a fan of the club but
you've probably been asked this before
but how did you discover the club and
why did you decide to become a supporter
best wishes
Elliot well I mean the story of AFC
Wimbledon is amazing because they were
originally this club when Wimbledon FC
and then owners basically stole the club
away and moved it to Milton Keynes where
there is now a club called MK Dons that
plays many miles away from Wimbledon in
Milton Keynes and so that the people of
Wimbledon started their own Football
Club way down in the amateur ranks and
then worked their way up through the
English league system and became a
full-time league club again and today
you know sell out their stadium every
weekend I first became aware of that
story when I think right before
Wimbledon got back into the Football
League in like 2009 and 2010 when they
were just won promotion away from being
a full-time professional club again and
I sort of followed them in in that
league and then when they
when they won this amazing game on
penalties with with Seb Brown there
their 19 year old goalkeeper saving two
penalties in the shootout that's when I
really became addicted to AFC Wimbledon
and I just feel really lucky because
there's such a great Club they reflect
the values that I like in soccer like I
you know one of the only things that I
think is of real value in soccer is the
community building aspect of it and AFC
Wimbledon is owned equally by every one
of its fans you know my five-year-old
son owns just as much of AFC Wimbledon
as I do and just as much of AFC
Wimbledon as the chairman of the club
does and I think it's pretty magical
that you know these thousands of people
working together and collaborating have
been able to rebuild something that was
special to them and turned it into
something that in a lot of ways is even
cooler than it used to be so AFC
Wimbledon is pretty great nothing
against Mars because Mars is also a nice
tank by the way I read the Martian oh
yeah yeah how did you like it it was
great
holy snoot it's a good book it's intense
yeah yeah a lot of life-or-death math
right yeah yeah was I was really
exciting and I felt like I learned a lot
about Mars along the way I don't know
how good the science is but it was
convincing to me yeah it's pretty good
science
speaking of which Hank I suppose that we
should maybe perhaps move on to the news
from Mars if there is any well in in
this week's news from Mars I want to
play you a clip John I'd like to play
you a clip that is from from this guy
whose name is John Green and this is
from a video he made in 2009 are you
ready for the clip did you hear that
John did you hear about what your what
your first favorite planet is I mean the
first my first response is that do you
remember in 2009 Hank when we made
videos and this was our delivery I mean
I like the planet Mars
to scream at the camera I mean did I
like did I like my viewers or was I
trying to attack them with my voice um
well I mean I don't know what to say do
this is this this was sent to me by
Michael Benzer who who is going through
old vlogbrothers videos and found this
and sent it to me for foreplay on the
podcast thank thank you very much
Michael well it's a difficult day for me
because I have to acknowledge that in
2009 apparently for a white-hot moment I
briefly in a joke said that Mars was my
favorite planet in fact Mars is tied for
second among my favorite planets but
it's tied with literally all the planets
that aren't earth so it's tied for
second it's also tied for eighth Hank
the news from AFC Wimbledon it's good
and bad just like the news it really is
is for any at any time in human history
you know you can always find the good
and you can always find the bad AFC
Wimbledon's senior men's team drew this
week against Mansfield they tied a tie
is not a bad result you know but it's I
I think that you know obviously we wish
that we were on top of the league to
table right now and and instead of being
on top we're 13th which is just under
the halfway point but you know whatever
a top 13 I'll take it but in incredibly
exciting news the AFC Wimbledon ladies
won a recent game in the women's FA Cup
nine to nothing nine they scored nine
goals they won nine to nothing and I I
have to I have to give a lot of credit
to AFC Wimbledon's women's football
program they're really good and there
are lots of professional teams including
like huge teams like Manchester United
that field no women's team at all and
that don't support women's football at
all and AFC Wimbledon is is tremendously
supportive of their women's football
team and also their youth their youth
girls teams as well as the youth boys
teams and I
it's one of one of you know many many
super cool things about the club so
congratulations to the AFC Wimbledon
ladies on their nine nil first round FA
Cup victory that is pretty impressive
I have not scored nine goals in my
entire football career how many girls
have you scored in your football career
job well I scored one goal in middle
school and then you know I scored a few
goals in club soccer in elementary
school in middle school but for my
middle school you know like school team
I just I only scored one goal it was in
a in a six nil victory as I recall and
it was the sixth goal it was the it was
the the nail the nail in the coffin the
final nail in the coffin and I scored it
from about eight inches out from the
goal more than scoring a goal this there
was one guy from England on our on our
middle school soccer team who was really
good his name was James and he could
kick the ball so hard he could just kick
the ball so much harder than any of the
rest of us and my recollection is that
we had a corner kick and James kicked
the ball so incredibly hard and it just
sort of hit my knee and dribbled into
the goal well done thank you I'm proud
of I appreciate it I believe I scored
one one goal and my soccer career is
well you mostly play goalie I did mostly
play goalie yes but I I did occasionally
not play goalie and I believe I scored
one goal during the times when I wasn't
playing as goalie I did not score a
goalie goal as awesome awesome as that
would have been oh those are the best so
I did get an assister too as a goalie
yeah yeah and that's a thing I kind of
feel like as a goalie it can't really
shouldn't really be counted as an assist
but you know whatever
in in this week's Mars news you may have
heard that there is whoa whoa whoa I
thought we just had the news from Mars
what was that but you thought you that
you liked Mars once in 2009 yeah I mean
that's breaking news like I am a
longtime opponent of Mars and you've
just dredged up a clip via a listen
that proves that I'm a flip-flopper
that's news there's more news for Mars
there's always news from Mars John
there's there's always too much news I
can never never quite quite give you all
the news from Mars because there's just
so much because it's a whole planet but
but this week's news from Mars you may
have heard that Apple just had a bunch
of new slightly different versions of
its own previous products last week
they're very excited about and they
would like us to acquire but if you like
better newer cooler versions of existing
content then boy are you gonna love the
Mars 2020 Rover planned for launch in
2020 which is a lot like curiosity but
is different and has a bunch of new
exciting proposed scientific instruments
including the Mars helicopter Scout
which is a solar-powered helicopter
drone that could pinpoint interesting
targets for study and plan the best
driving route for the drone like go
ahead and like take pictures so that we
would know where where the where the the
rover would go so that's cool it would
fly it would fly out and it would fly
back in charge and so it would be like
sort of like a just sort of extend the
range of the rover's visual sensors
which is just I love that idea it's so
cool that's all how big is this Martian
helicopter that we're building it'll
weigh about a kilogram John let me ask a
follow-up question how how much work do
we need to do on Mars in the next say
six to nine months to ensure that it is
fully habitable in the event but a solar
flare makes it impossible for me to
charge my iPhone you might want to buy
some solar panels John oh I'm buying
solar panels that's that's and a bicycle
generator by all means I'm also gonna
hire someone to pedal that bicycle just
you what are you talking about you have
a child
to just make your child do it I've made
a bunch of capital outlays just in the
last 15 minutes Hank to deal with this
new crisis that I didn't know about
that's what children are for John to
pedal your bicycle powered generator
oh man oh truly spoken like someone who
doesn't have children I can't even get
them to like eat dinner let alone power
my generator Oh God
all right Hank what did we learn today
we learned of course that a a solar
flare is going to destroy all life on
Earth and that I'm going to die and not
only am I going to die I'm not even
gonna be able to take a selfie of myself
dying because my phone won't charge we
learned that John has a lot of
experience with heartbreak and having
his not run into his mouth while saying
why hast thou forsaken me for reasons of
being dumped whereas the why the reasons
why I have said why hath thou forsaken
me with snot dripping into my mouth has
less to do with being dumped but thanks
to everybody for listening to today's
show even to our cruel and unusual
listeners who dug up evidence that I
once briefly expressed an affinity
toward Mars but yeah thank you guys so
much for listening and and for your
responses on on Twitter on soundcloud
and in the itunes comments it's it's so
awesome to read them we really
appreciate it
if you have questions for us that you
would like to hear our answers to or get
some dubious advice you can email us at
Hank and John at gmail.com
the podcast is edited by Nicholas
Jenkins this theme music that you're
hearing right now is from gunnarolla and
as they say in our hometown don't forget
to be awesome
[Music]